This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗压能力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。名字就是两个百分号。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他罪有应得。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友们。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回望过去》（The Look Back at it）播客。对1979年来说，那是对我而言意义重大的一年。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回望过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《知难而进》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都实在不够安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《知难而进》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Okay, if the audio sounds a little bit different on this episode, it's because Sydney Airport today decided that it would be really fun to divert all of the airport traffic over my house.
大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，在这里我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析二十岁的心理学。好吧，如果这集节目的音频听起来有点不同，那是因为悉尼机场今天决定，把所有的机场交通改道飞过我的房子，这绝对是个“好主意”。
So I was like trying to record this. I have tried to do like this episode four or five times. And every time I'm about to get into it, like a DHL mega cargo plane is like a kilometer away from like my windows. So we kind of change things up today. And I'm recording in my like hallway cupboard situation. So breaking the fourth wall there to address if this sounds like a little bit different from my other episodes. But today, guys, we're going to do a little bit more of a personal episode.
所以我当时就像是在努力录制这个。我已经尝试录制这一集四五次了。而且每次当我快要进入状态时，比如一架DHL大型货运飞机就像是在我的窗户大约一公里外飞过。所以我们今天得变通一下。我现在是在我的走廊储藏室里录音。所以打破第四堵墙来解释一下，为什么这集听起来可能跟我的其他节目有点不一样。但今天，伙计们，我们要聊一聊更私人的一集。
Obviously, I like to talk about our 20s in general and I like to have like psychological conversations around why we experience what we do, when we do in this decade, why it's so chaotic. But every now and again, I do like to do a little bit more of a personal episode, more so for me. I feel like this podcast is many things to many people. But for me, it's also kind of like a personal diary or a little bit of like a kind of like one of those things called a time capsule where I want to do certain episodes specifically for future me to listen to and to reflect on. And this today is one of those episodes. A couple of months ago I released one of my favorite episodes ever, which was the 20 biggest mistakes people make in their 20s. That was like
显然，我喜欢总体上谈论我们的二十岁，我也喜欢围绕我们为什么会经历这些、为什么在这个十年经历这些、以及为什么这个十年如此混乱，展开心理学层面的对话。但每隔一段时间，我也确实喜欢做一期更私人的节目，更多是为了我自己。我觉得这个播客对很多人来说有很多意义。但对我来说，它也某种程度上像是我的个人日记，或者像是某种被称为时间胶囊的东西，我想制作特定的几集，专门留给未来的我去听、去反思。今天的这一集就是其中之一。几个月前，我发布了我最喜欢的节目之一，即“人在二十多岁时犯下的20个最大错误”。那期节目真的……
so many months of work went into that episode. And it basically, it basically, just, you know, we talked to over 5,000 people about what they regretted and why. And since that, I've really started to think about, hey, like, do I regret about my 20s so far? What are the things that I might point to later on in life and say, oh, I wish I'd done that differently. And so since that episode has come out, I've kind of started compiling my own list and like writing things down here and there, both like from recent memory and from like my much earlier 20s. And today I thought that I would share that list. Now, especially as I'm kind of definitely entering my later 20s, I have found that I've become more reflective. I'm definitely waiting for my Saturn return to like come and kick me in the
花了无数个月的心血才完成。它基本上，基本上，就是，你知道的，我们采访了5000多人，了解他们最后悔的是什么以及原因。自那以后，我真的开始思考：嘿，到目前为止，我对自己的二十岁有什么遗憾吗？未来在生活中，我可能会指出哪些事情，并说“哦，我真希望当时能换一种方式做”？所以自从那期节目播出后，我就开始整理我自己的清单，零零散散地把一些事情写下来，既有最近的记忆，也有我二十岁刚出头时的回忆。今天我想和大家分享这个清单。特别是随着我确定无疑地步入二十岁的后半程，我发现自己变得越来越爱反思。我绝对在等待我的“土星回归”来狠狠地……
butt. And before that happens, I want to make sure that like I have been taking as many lessons as I can from my experiences and that the stuff that I'm going through, whether good or bad, will actually stay with me. So this is kind of the combination of all of that thinking. And all of that reflecting on what I regret, what I would change, how I want to kind of go into the last few years of my 20s really prioritizing and thinking about. And I thought maybe just maybe someone else could benefit from this as well. So without further ado, we're going to talk about my 10 biggest regrets from my 20s so far, spanning from dating to friendship to money, my health, how I've made use of my time and certain chapters of my life, and so many other things.
踢我的屁股。在那之前，我想确保我能从自己的经历中吸取尽可能多的教训，确保我正在经历的事情，无论是好是坏，都能真正留在我心中。所以这可以说是所有这些思考的结合。以及对我的遗憾、我想改变的地方，以及我想如何在二十岁的最后几年里真正把什么放在首位并进行思考的所有反思。我想也许，哪怕只是也许，其他人也能从中受益。废话不多说，我们要来聊聊我二十岁至今的十大遗憾，涵盖了从约会、友情、金钱、健康，到我对时间的利用、我人生中的某些篇章，以及许多其他事情。
I hope you enjoy. I hope you learn something. Let's get into it. Okay, so when I was thinking about one of my biggest regrets, the first one was so painstakingly, like, obvious to me. Like, there is no question that the biggest regret I have so far is, doing things for others that I really didn't want to do. That's my biggest regret. Number one is all the times when I have felt deep in my stomach and deep in my body, I don't want to do this. I don't want to be here. Why did I say yes to this? Why do I continue to say yes to these things? And yet,
希望你们喜欢。希望你们能有所收获。我们切入正题吧。好吧，当我思考我最大的遗憾之一时，第一个遗憾是如此刻骨铭心、显而易见。毫无疑问，到目前为止，我最大的遗憾就是：为那些我真的不想做的事情去迎合别人。这就是我最大的遗憾。第一名就是所有那些时候，我内心深处、身体深处都清晰地感受到：我不想做这件事。我不想呆在这里。我为什么要答应这个？我为什么还要继续对这些事情说“好”？然而……
I'm still in that situation time and time again. This is probably the biggest thing that I am currently trying to sort out within myself and trying to make better. I think at least once a week, I have like a conversation with myself where I'm like, what are we doing? Why did we agree to go to this event? Why do we agree to say yes to this thing, even though like it's incredibly like time heavy and you're not getting paid anything and you don't even like these people? Like, that was a recent one where I was like, what am I, why did I say yes to that?
我却一次又一次地陷入这种境地。这可能是我目前正在努力在自己内部理顺并试图改善的最大问题。我想至少一周一次，我会和自己进行这样的对话：“我们在干什么？我们为什么要答应去参加这个活动？我们为什么同意答应这件事，尽管它极其耗费时间，你一分钱也拿不到，而且你甚至根本不喜欢这些人？”这是一个最近的例子，当时我就在想：“我到底在干什么，我为什么要答应那个？”
Why did I agree to help with this person's, I don't know, baby shower when they've never actually ever been very nice to me? Why did I do this favor for someone? Like, it's a repeat pattern that I honestly find myself in more often than I want to be. And I regret it. I regret it every single time. I think when I really like break down why this is happening, like it's historical. It's deeply historical and it's deeply like related to the worth I felt as a child.
为什么我同意帮某人的，我不知道，婴儿送礼会（baby shower）忙，而这个人其实从来没有对我真正好过？我为什么要为某人做这个顺水人情？这是一个重复出现的模式，老实说，我发现自己陷入其中的频率远超我的预期。我为此感到后悔。每一次我都后悔。我想，当我真正剖析这背后的原因时，它是历史性的。这深深地带有历史根源，并且深深地与我作为孩子时感受到的自我价值有关。
And I've spoken about this on the podcast before. But when I was a kid, when I was in primary school and even when I was in high school, I was bullied really, really badly. And I had all these experiences where I really wanted a friend and I really wanted people to like me and like I just couldn't figure it out. Like all these other kids seem to just like have this quality about them that made other people like them and I didn't have that quality. In fact, I had the quality that made people find me irritating or not like me or kind of
我在播客里也谈到过这一点。但当我还是个孩子时，当我读小学甚至上高中文的时候，我遭受过非常、非常严重的霸凌。我有过所有这些经历：我非常渴望有个朋友，我非常渴望别人喜欢我，但我就是搞不懂。所有其他孩子似乎都自带某种特质，让别人喜欢他们，而我没有这种特质。事实上，我身上的特质只会让别人觉得我很烦、不喜欢我，或者在某种程度上……
victimized me in a bit of a way. And so as I got older, I think one of the strategies I learnt is that if you just constantly do things for other people, then they'll like you more. if you are constantly like the yes person and the pushover, you get invited. You get to see behind the scenes. People include you, and they include you, maybe not because they consciously know this, but unconsciously because they know that you will help them and you will bend over backwards for them and you will sacrifice for them and you won't stand up for yourself.
把我当作受害者。所以随着我长大，我认为我学到的策略之一就是：如果你不断地为别人做事，他们就会更喜欢你。如果你总是扮演那个唯命是从的“老好人”，你就会受到邀请。你就能窥见幕后。人们会接纳你，他们接纳你，也许不是因为他们有意识地知道这一点，而是因为他们潜意识里知道你会帮助他们，你会为他们赴汤蹈火，你会为他们做出牺牲，而且你不会为自己挺身而出。
this obviously was like very helpful to me and I have to acknowledge it was helpful for me when I was younger and when I just really wanted to be liked and I really just needed a friend. Nowadays like I have friends and I have a really great life and I feel a lot more confident. I have a much greater sense of self-esteem. This is no longer helpful for me and it's no longer useful and in fact it's like really starting to cost me. And I'm trying not to go into specifics because, like, I'm sure there are people who I've said yes to when I really didn't want to do things in the past who I'm listening to this podcast. And the thing is, is that it's not their fault, right? It's, this is another lesson.
这在当时对我的确非常有用，我必须承认，当我年纪还小、极度渴望被喜欢、极度需要一个朋友的时候，这对我很有帮助。如今，我有朋友，我有非常棒的生活，我感到自信得多。我的自尊心要强得多。这对我来说不再有帮助，也不再有用了，事实上，它开始让我付出沉重的代价。我尽量不扯进具体的细节里去，因为，我觉得，过去那些我明明不想做、却还是答应了的人，现在可能也在听这个播客。问题在于，这并不是他们的错，对吧？这是另一个教训。
Like, it's not someone's fault if I continue to say yes when I want to say no. Yes, there is certainly, like, perhaps layers of recognition that this is a weakness of mine and maybe a desire to manipulate. that without them knowing it. But at the end of the day, these things that I'm saying yes to are relatively like low stakes. They're just irritating to continually do. I kind of have to, I don't know, I need to like warm up and say no to these things. That's a summary of my biggest regret. And obviously you can tell that it's something that I'm still trying to undo and hopefully in five years time when I'm making like the final complete list of my regrets of my 20s all up. This does not make the list and it is something that I have recovered from. But yeah, I'm
如果我想说“不”却总是说“好”，这并不是别人的错。当然，其中可能有一层层的认知——意识到这是我的弱点，也许还有一种在他们不知情的情况下试图操纵的欲望。但归根结底，我所答应的这些事情风险相对较低。它们只是不断去做时会让人觉得很烦恼。我需要，我不知道，我需要热热身，学会对这些事情说“不”。这就是我最大遗憾的总结。显而易见，你可以看出这仍然是我试图去扭转的事情，希望五年后，当我列出我整个二十岁所有遗憾的最终完整清单时，这一条不会上榜，而是成为我已经克服的问题。不过，是的，我……
sure a lot of people can relate to it. My second biggest regret, like I feel like the first one is very existential and very much about like self-concept and self-respect and childhood wounds. This next one is not so much. It is impulse buying clothes that weren't comfortable or didn't fit or I knew I would never wear. Big tone shift there, a big one. 80, but I'm obviously like preparing to move countries at the end of the year. Like visas are approved, flights are booked, plans and preparations are in process. And I am like looking through my wardrobe and realizing that I may have like an impulse spending problem and that I buy a lot of stuff that I never wear.
确信很多人都能对此感同身受。我第二大的遗憾，我觉得第一点非常存在主义，非常关于自我概念、自尊和童年创伤。接下来这一条就没那么深奥了。那就是冲动购买那些不舒服、不合身、或者我知道自己永远不会穿的衣服。这里语调来了个急转弯，转得很大。80，但我显然在为年底搬去别的国家做准备。签证已经批了，机票已经订好了，计划和准备工作都在进行中。而我正在翻看自己的衣柜，突然意识到我可能患有冲动消费症，而且我买了很多从来不穿的东西。
And it is a huge money pit for me. I genuinely think I wear the same six outfits. Like, I, yeah, I really, like, I've been doing the math and I've been asking myself the question and getting rid of things. Like, have I worn this in the last six months? And there are probably, like, 12 items of clothing that I genuinely wear. And the rest is just stuff that, like, sits there and is filled with the potential of, like, maybe one day I'll wear this. maybe one day I'll be confident enough to wear that. Maybe one day I'll suddenly be this different person who wears these things.
这对我来说是一个巨大的金钱黑洞。我真心觉得我来来回回就穿那六套衣服。真的，是的，我一直在算账，一直在问自己这个问题，并开始清理衣物。比如：我在过去六个月里穿过这个吗？大概只有12件衣服是我真正会穿的。剩下的都只是放在那里，充斥着某种潜力，比如：也许有一天我会穿这个；也许有一天我会有足够的自信穿那个；也许有一天我会突然变成一个会穿这些衣服的截然不同的人。
And I just kind of know that I'm not. Like, I know that these things don't make me comfortable. And I just really regret how much money I have put into clothes or items that I thought were going to be the final thing that made me feel good. Or like, the final thing that was going to fill the void or like the final item that I needed to have the most perfect wardrobe and feel confident every. every single time I put something on. It is honestly just a waste of space. And I am seriously considering doing a little bit of a capsule wardrobe, just selling everything except for like the clothes I know I wear on a daily.
但我心里其实很清楚，我不是这样的人。我知道这些衣服并不能让我感到舒适。我真的很后悔，自己把那么多的钱花在了那些我认为能让自己感觉良好的衣服或物品上。或者觉得这会是填补内心空虚的最后一件东西，或者是我拥有最完美衣橱、每次穿上都能感到自信所需的最后一件单品。老实说，这简直就是浪费空间。我正在认真考虑弄一个“胶囊衣橱”（capsule衣橱），除了那些我知道自己日常会穿的衣服外，把其他的全部卖掉。
And starting from scratch or just like not buying anything else and seeing how long I can last, I feel like my move to London is going to be a great opportunity for me to try out the minimalist lifestyle. I don't know how successful I will be. but yeah, the second biggest regret is the money that I have put into clothes and items that were really just like representing my desire to be someone that I was not. And I haven't like really recognized that until now. My third biggest regret now it kind of turns more towards relationships.
然后从零开始，或者干脆什么都不买，看看我能坚持多久。我觉得搬去伦敦对我来说将是一个极好的机会，可以让我尝试极简主义的生活方式。我不知道自己能有多成功，但好吧，第二大遗憾就是我把钱投入到了那些实际上只是代表了“我想成为一个并非真正的我”的欲望的衣服和物品中。直到现在我才真正意识到这一点。我的第三大遗憾，现在它更多地转向了人际关系。
And I honestly think it's one that I wasn't like I know this was one I wasn't going to include because of how it may make me look like a bad person or may make me look inconsiderate, but it is ghosting friends, even people who weren't not good friends to me. There is like one person in particular that I think about who our friendship was deeply problematic for many reasons, emotional but also financial reasons,
老实说，一开始我并不打算把它写进去，因为这可能会让我看起来像个坏人，或者显得很不体贴。但这就是——对朋友进行“幽灵式失联”（ghosting），甚至是对那些对我不算好的人。我脑海里特别浮现出一个人，由于种种原因，我们的友谊在很多方面都存在严重的问题，不仅有情感上的，还有财务上的原因。
like at the end of the day, the reason it didn't last was because of how this person treated money and how they kind of took advantage of me for money in a way that felt like really awful. And I know that we weren't meant to be friends and that there were things that couldn't be repaired. But I really regret not having that final conversation with this person and not just clearing the air. I don't think it would have done anything. I don't think that they would have changed, but sometimes I, yeah, I just, maybe they wouldn't have seen that it was an issue, but I really regret not giving them that and not giving myself that as well. And my freaking phone has been doing this thing where they have, where it's been like showing me photos of this person.
归根结底，我们这段友情没能维持下去的原因，是因为这个人对待金钱的态度，以及他们某种程度上在金钱上占我便宜的方式，让我觉得非常糟糕。我知道我们注定不是朋友，有些事情是无法修复的。但我真的很后悔没有和这个人进行最后那次谈话，没有把话说开。我不认为这能改变什么。我不认为他们会有所改变，但有时我，是的，我只是……也许他们不会觉得这是个问题，但我真的很后悔没有给他们这个机会，也没有给自己这个机会。该死的手机一直在搞这出，它一直在向我展示这个人的照片。
like every single day I get a photo of this previous friend and I can't stop thinking about them and yeah like wanting to reach out but also knowing it's not for the best and I just think that that is a lesson that the only thing left in that is the lesson to not do that in the future and to have hard conversations. I've definitely done it in the past as well but I do think that my default is to just like not hurt people's feelings and to not want to let people down. not realizing that sometimes that's kind of selfish. Like, it's kind of selfish to not want to experience the discomfort of upsetting people, but therefore maybe actually making it a more upsetting experience for them.
就像每一天我都会收到一张这个前朋友的照片，我无法停止想他们，是的，既想联系他们，又知道这样做并不是最好的选择。我想这其中留下的唯一教训就是：不要在未来重蹈覆辙，要敢于进行艰难的对话。我过去肯定也做过类似的事，但我确实认为我的默认设定就是不想伤害别人的感情，不想让别人失望。却没意识到有时候这其实是一种自私。不想去经历那种让别人不高兴的不适感，其实是一种自私，因为这反而可能让对方经历更多的不愉快。
Big lessons in that, but it has been a regret of mine, and I wish that I could go back and finish certain friendships and finish certain relationships better. maybe not relationships. I will say, I feel like I'm someone who's pretty good to break up with and I'm good at doing the breaking up, but definitely friendships. Like, I just feel like the way that you really love someone is reflected in how the relationship ends.
从中吸取了巨大的教训，但这确实是我的一个遗憾，我希望自己能回到过去，更好地为某些友情画上句号，更好地结束某些关系。也许不是恋爱关系吧。我得说，我觉得我在提分手这方面处理得挺好，我也很擅长去处理分手这事，但友情绝对是个例外。我觉得，你究竟有多爱一个人，其实体现在这段关系是如何结束的。
And I definitely could have honored other friendships and friendships of mine better in the goodbye. That's regret number three. Let's talk about regret number four before we take a second. short break. And this is one that I think, I wish, I wish someone had told me at 19 and I had listened to them, although I don't think I would have. I regret focusing too much on dating in my early 20s. If you are 19 or younger, or if you are 20 or 21, listen to me closely right now. If you do not have a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a partner right now and you are thinking that you need one to kind of fulfill other people's expectations or to make you happier, you do not. Please, please, be single right now, have a lot of fun, make a lot of amazing friendships.
我本可以在告别时更好地尊重我的其他友谊和友情。这就是第三大遗憾。在我们进入短暂的休息之前，我们来聊聊第四大遗憾。我觉得这一条，我真希望，我真希望在我19岁的时候有人能这么告诉我，而且我能听进去，虽然我觉得我当时可能听不进去。我后悔在二十岁出头时把太多精力放在约会上。如果你是19岁或更年轻，或者如果你是20岁或21岁，现在请仔细听我说。如果你现在没有男朋友、女朋友或伴侣，并且你认为你需要一个来满足别人的期望或者让你更快乐，你其实并不需要。求求你，现在保持单身吧，好好玩乐，结交大量精彩的朋友。
Make the first five years of your 20s be about building stable community and a support network. you do not need to start focusing on dating until you are at least 25. And I know that that brings up complicated feelings. I know that a lot of people may have met the love of their life in their early 20s, and it's worked out incidentally, like really amazing. And I know a lot of people have a lot of fears around being a late bloomer or never finding anybody or not having experience. But I am telling you from my perspective and looking back at my life,
让你的二十岁前五年专注于建立稳定的社区和支持网络。直到你至少25岁之前，你都不需要把精力集中在约会上。我知道这会带来复杂的情感。我知道很多人可能在二十岁出头时就遇到了他们一生的挚爱，而且阴差阳错地结果非常美好。我也知道很多人对成为“晚熟的人”、或者永远找不到任何人、或者缺乏经验有着种种恐惧。但我从我的视角、从回首我的人生来看，我告诉你们：
I regret so deeply how much time and energy I put into trying to make men like me, trying to fall in love, trying to force relationships that did not work, when I could have spent all of that energy on so much else. Like there was a particular relationship I had in my early 20s. Like when I was 21, I went through two breakups in one year. And in that same period of time, like being in those relationships, like decimated half of my friendships. And oh my God, for what? Like genuinely for what? I take like full accountability for the fact that, you know, being in that relationship was a terrible
我深深地后悔，自己曾花费了多少时间和精力去试图讨好男人、试图坠入爱河、试图强求那些根本行不通的关系，而我本可以把所有这些精力花在更多其他事情上。比如我在二十岁出头时有一段特定的感情。就像我21岁那年，我在一年里经历了两次分手。而在那同一时期，身处那些恋爱关系中，摧毁了我一半的友情。我的天哪，到底是为了什么？真心实意地问，到底是为了什么？我承担全部的责任——因为身处那段感情中是一个糟糕的……
decision and made me act terribly as a person. And I just wish I could, like, I didn't really learn anything from it. I can like fully say that now. Like I don't think I learned much from it other than that I shouldn't do that again. And, you know, I can never get back, like, that time, and I can never get back the friendships that, like, my selfishness in that relationship ruined. And I just wish, like, I have younger sisters. And I was talking to them because they were staying with me this weekend. And I was, like, probably, like, scaring them a little bit.
决定，并让我作为一个人的行为变得糟糕透顶。我只希望我能，我其实并没有从中学到什么，我现在完全可以这样说。我觉得除了“我不应该再那样做”之外，我没学到什么东西。而且，你知道的，我再也找不回那段时光了，我也再找不回那些因为我在那段关系中的自私而被毁掉的友情。我只希望，我有一些年轻的妹妹。我跟她们谈过心，因为她们这周末一直跟我住在一起。然后我，就像是，可能把她们吓到了那么一点点。
But I was like, are you guys dating anyone? And they were like, none of your business. And I was like, well, you shouldn't be. Tell me. But also, like, break up. with them. Like, you need to be single. Like, move to London with me. Like, move to Sydney. Like, just do something wild and adventurous and crazy whilst you can, because you will meet someone eventually. And if you don't, you will still benefit more from spending that time
但我当时问：“你们在跟谁约会吗？”她们说：“关你屁事。”我说：“你们就不该约会。老实交代。而且，赶紧跟他们分手。”“就像这样。你需要单身。就像跟我一起搬去伦敦。就像搬去悉尼。去做一些疯狂、冒险、顺心所欲的事吧，趁你还能这么做，因为你最终总会遇到某人的。如果你没有遇到，你从这段时间里获得的益处依然会更多——”
building self-confidence and self-love and a really rich ecosystem of friendships and relationships rather than just, like, kind of martying yourself for people who don't respect you. this kind of brings me, sorry, I know I said I take a break, but this fifth regret is actually really relevant to this. And that is tolerating bad behavior from people I was dating because I wanted validation. And that really kind of comes back to that relationship I was talking about. Like the disrespect that I let happen, and I'm not like blaming myself, but like the disrespect that I overlooked because I wanted this mediocre person to like me is wild in hindsight. Like the way this person would make me feel, the way he would like talk down to me in front of
通过建立自信、自爱以及一个真正丰富的友情和关系生态系统，而不是为了那些不尊重你的人把自己搞得像个殉道者一样。这自然而然地引出了，抱歉，我知道我刚才说要休息一下，但这第五个遗憾实际上和这一点息息相关。那就是：为了寻求认同感，我去容忍那些和我约会的人的糟糕行为。这其实又回到了我刚才谈到的那段关系。回想起来，我当时竟然容忍了那种不尊重，我并不是在责怪自己，但我竟然为了让这个平庸的人喜欢我而忽视了那种不尊重，这在事后看来简直太荒谬了。比如这个人让我感受到的方式，他在其他人面前贬低我的方式，他否定我热爱的事物的方式，他从未满足过我的情感需求，然而我却依然不断地回到他身边并崇拜他，这让我感到非常遗憾。这是一个巨大的遗憾。
others, the way he would discredit my passions, the way he would never like meet my emotional needs and yet I continue to like come back to him and like worship him is a huge regret for me. It's a massive one. The question that I wish I'd ask myself in which I now tell people to ask themselves in these similar situations is, if this was your soulmate, would your soulmate treat you this way? Is this how you want to be loved for the rest of your life? Because I think in our 20s, sometimes the stakes don't feel that high, right? It doesn't really feel like this person is going to be forever. But, like, it doesn't matter every moment that you stay in those situations where your confidence and your sense of self and your sense of self-esteem is like degraded is a moment
我希望当时能问自己、而我现在也告诉人们在类似情况下要问自己的问题是：如果这个人是你的灵魂伴侣，你的灵魂伴侣会这样对你吗？这就是你余生想要被爱的方式吗？因为我觉得在我们二十岁的时候，有时候赌注感觉没那么高，对吧？感觉这个人并不会陪你走到永远。但是，话虽如此，你在那些让你的自信、自我意识和自尊心受到贬低的情境中停留的每一分每一秒，都是你再也无法找回的时光，而且这至关重要。所以我真希望当时没有这样做，我真希望自己能态度强硬一点。我真希望自己能早点及时止损。你知道吗？
you don't get back and is important. So I wish I hadn't, I wish I'd put my foot down. I wish that I'd just cut my losses a bit sooner. And you know what? I wish in kind of a cruel way, that I'd had like that final moment to like look this person in the eye and be like, you really have lost out. Like there's a cell, like this like little like cheeky kind of mean part of me that's like God, I wish I could have just like given them a piece of my mind. Maybe not immediately when we broke up because like the way I broke up with this person was like a whisper rather than a shout.
带着某种残酷的想法，我真希望当时能有那么一个最后的时刻，直视这个人的眼睛，对他说：“你真的是彻底错过了一个好人。”就像心底里有一个小小的、有点调皮又带点刻薄的我，在想：“天哪，我真希望能狠狠地骂醒他们。”也许不是在我们分手的那一刻，因为当时我跟这个人分手时说得轻声细语，而不是大吵大闹。
But I wish that like six months later I'd run into him. and I could have just been like, yeah, like, I don't know. Maybe it's like a reclaiming of the confidence I wish I had during that period. But okay, I promised us a break. I promised some time for you guys to go get some tea to enjoy my ads. So stay with us. We will be right back. 2%.
但我真希望在六个月后我能偶遇他，然后我就可以直接说：“是的，就像是，我不知道。”也许这就好像是重新找回我希望自己在那个时期拥有的自信。好吧，我答应过要休息的。我答应过给你们一点时间去泡杯茶、好好欣赏一下广告。所以请不要走开。我们马上回来。《2%》。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
这是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗压能力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导大健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。名字就是两个百分号。
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？你可以在《回望过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的“快克”（crack）毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不单单是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，到了这一步，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把话说完。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在谈论。特里普·方丹，
Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about
瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们却还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了……
wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得作为一个活在世上的好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now.
我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，让我们就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency, in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular
在2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她说法中……耀眼的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的……
test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
测试，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐，惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back. As a reminder, we are talking about the 10 biggest regrettable. that I have about my 20s so far. We have talked about relationships.
在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱的陷阱》播客。欢迎回来。提醒一下，我们正在讨论我关于二十岁的十大遗憾。我们聊了人际关系。
We've talked about shopping randomly. We've talked about ghosting friends. I want to talk now more about how I chose to use my time and my energy. And this, what are we up to? Sixth regret has to do with journaling, actually, and how I processed emotions or took notes of pivotal points in my life. I wish that I had journaled more, especially in my early 20s, rather than relying on my memory to accurately describe things. When I was a teenager, I have these incredibly intricate journals and reflections on my life.
我们聊了盲目购物。我们聊了对朋友幽灵式失联。现在我想更多地谈谈我是如何选择利用我的时间和精力的。这个，我们进行到第几个了？第六个遗憾其实与写日记有关，以及我是如何处理情绪或记录我人生的关键转折点的。我真希望自己当时能多写写日记，尤其是在我二十岁出头的时候，而不是依赖我的记忆来准确描述事情。当我还是个青少年时，我有着极其复杂的日记和对人生的反思。
And there are all these characters and there are all these like plot twists that actually happened to me. And it's honestly really delightful, like reading them back. back. I feel as if people journal for two reasons. They journal for emotional processing and as a form of coping. And they also journal as a form of memory keeping and as a way to see a coherent, so to kind of be able to see the story of their life. Right. And there is this big chunk of my story that is missing if you were only to read my journals because I just, I would, was so distracted that I didn't do it and I didn't think it was important. And I just really regret that because I wish I had a more, I was going to say objective, but like objective as in of the time
里面有各种各样的人物，还有所有那些真正发生在我身上的剧情反转。老实说，回头再读这些真的非常有趣。我感觉人们写日记有两个原因。他们写日记是为了处理情绪和作为一种应对机制。他们也把写日记作为一种保存记忆的方式，作为一种看到连贯脉络的方式，从而能够看清自己人生的故事。对吧。如果只读我的日记，你会发现我的故事中有一大块是缺失的，因为我当时……太分心了，所以没坚持写，也没觉得这很重要。我真的对此感到很遗憾，因为我希望自己能有一个更——我本来想说客观，但就像是当时那种……
recount of what I was going through and what I was learning at that time. I guess this episode is like a way to do that for me right now. And I guess maybe it really like aligned with when I started doing the podcast and I kind of felt like I didn't have to do it as much. But I did and I still do and now I'm kind of getting back into it. But I really wish that I'd done that more. It's such an important practice for me, and I don't know necessarily why I neglected it, but I know I regret it.
客观的重述，记录下我当时正在经历什么以及我当时学到了什么。我想这集播客就像是现在为我做这件事的一种方式。我想这也许真的与我开始做播客的时间相吻合，当时我某种程度上觉得我不需要写得那么频繁了。但我确实写过，现在也还在写，而且我现在正慢慢捡回来。但我真的很希望自己当时能多写一点。对我来说这是一个如此重要的习惯，我不知道自己为什么一定要忽视它，但我知道我很后悔。
My seventh regret is overthinking things rather than just doing them. And yet again, this is another kind of routine way that I operate, that I'm trying to not necessarily unlearned, but just acknowledge and be friends with. You know, I might, and probably will never change my brain's tendency to overthink, but I think I can overcome the instinct to just ruminate forever and ever and ever. My tendency to overthink rather than just do is both like innocuous and deeply like influential. It happens every single day.
我的第七个遗憾是过度思考事情，而不是直接去付诸行动。然而，这也是我行事的一种常规方式，我并不是非要改掉它，而是试图去认识它并与之和平相处。你知道，我可能永远也不会改变我大脑倾向于过度思考的习惯，但我认为我可以克服那种没完没了地反刍、纠结的本能。我倾向于过度思考而不是直接行动，这种倾向既无伤大雅，又影响深远。它每天都在发生。
It's like from small things like not being able to. but to choose an ice cream flavor and then like getting to the counter and having something in mind that I want and then choosing something completely different and being disappointed to overthinking my future to the point where I don't ever act on certain things or don't ever act on opportunities because I've just been so obsessed over whether they're going to be right and whether they're going to set me on a path that I can't come back from. That's just like so ridiculous, right? Like, We have no idea how a decision is going to work out. I always give people advice to just do, to just make the decision,
这就像是从一些小事开始，比如无法做出选择一个冰淇淋口味的决定，然后走到柜台前，脑子里明明有想要的东西，结果却选了完全不同的东西，最后感到失望；再到过度思考我的未来，以至于我从不对某些事情采取行动，或者从不对机会采取行动，因为我太过于纠结它们是否会是正确的、是否会把我带上一条无法回头的路。这简直太荒谬了，对吧？我们根本不知道一个决定最终会带来什么结果。我总是给别人建议：直接去做，去做出决定，
to just go with one choice rather than going with no choice. And yet it's something that I still struggle with. I definitely do act and I definitely do make the decision eventually. But I just wonder how much time and opportunity I've wasted thinking about it, especially like to break the fourth wall yet again. when I think like in like year two of the podcast when like people were listening right really listening and it felt like I was doing something important rather than just a hobby I would obsessively think about which episodes to release next and it meant that I like had all
与其不做决定，不如选择其中一个选项。然而这也是我仍在苦苦挣扎的事情。我确实会付诸行动，我也最终会做出决定。但我只是在想，我到底浪费了多少时间和机会在思考上——特别是在——再次打破第四堵墙——当我回想在做播客的第二年时，当时人们在收听，是真的在收听，感觉我当时在做一件很重要的事情，而不仅仅是一个爱好，我会强迫性地思考下一期该发布什么节目，这意味着我有……
these really good ideas and I had all these stories that I think would have been really important to share and I didn't because I kept questioning and overthinking whether people would find them valuable rather than you know whether I would find. them valuable. And I feel like that was a big mistake and it's something that I, again, I regret. I've also done it with job opportunities in the past where I've overthought something to the point where they've basically been like, well, we're going to give it to someone else. And I totally respect that decision, but I wish that I wasn't in that situation. So something that I want to do in the next three years of my 20s is to just listen to.
所有这些非常棒的想法，我还有所有那些我认为分享出来会非常重要的故事，但我没有分享，因为我一直在质疑和过度思考人们是否会觉得它们有价值，而不是去考虑……我是否觉得它们有价值。我觉得那是一个巨大的错误，而且这是我，再次感到遗憾的事情。我过去在工作机会上也这样做过，我把某件事过度思考到最后人家基本上说：“好吧，我们要把它给别人了。”我完全尊重这个决定，但我真希望自己当时没有陷入那种境地。所以在二十岁接下来的三年里，我想做的一件事就是听从……
into my gut a little bit more and to just trust the first thought that comes into my brain, even if it's wrong. And this is what I think about this. I think that there is so much to be said about trial and error in further honing and fine-tuning your gut instinct and your intuition. The only way you can know what is intuition and what is anxiety is to just act on whatever comes up first and figure it out and then kind of reverse engineer or kind of understand in hindsight or distinguish in hindsight which was which right and what they why they like might suddenly feel differently so this is something that I want to be better at not trusting my gut instinct has also like gotten me in a lot of trouble in the past that kind of brings me to my eighth regret which is
更加倾听我的直觉，并且去相信脑海中冒出的第一个想法，即使它是错的。关于这一点，我认为在进一步打磨和微调你的直觉和第六感时，试错有着巨大的价值。你唯一的办法去分辨什么是直觉、什么是焦虑，就是直接根据最先浮现的想法去行动，然后弄清楚状况，事后进行复盘、理解或区分哪个是哪个，以及它们为什么可能会突然带给你不同的感受。所以这是我想做得更好的事情。过去不相信直觉也给我惹过很多麻烦，这就带出了我的第八个后悔，那就是
the times that I didn't trust my gut instinct when it came to large. financial decisions and letting people pressure me into things that I knew were not right and that I had a bad gut feeling about. I don't really talk about money on the show very much. Just because, to be real, I'm not particularly very good with money. Like, I'm definitely been more dedicated to learning about it and to investing in things and to using my money wisely. But like, I have an economics degree doesn't mean I really understand everyday financial decisions very well. But last year, I didn't necessarily lose, but I invested what was a very significant sum of money for me because of advice from someone else who I didn't want to disagree with.
在涉及重大财务决策时，我没有相信自己的直觉，而是让别人向我施压，去做那些我明知不对、而且直觉感到不妙的事情。我其实很少在节目里谈论金钱，只是因为老实说，我并不太擅长理财。比如，我肯定更致力于学习理财、投资以及明智地使用资金。但虽然我拥有经济学学位，并不意味着我真的能很好地理解日常的财务决策。不过去年，由于听信了某个我不想反驳的人的建议，我投资了一笔对当时的我和说相当大的一笔钱，虽说不上全亏了，
It's not that I wanted to impress them, but I felt like I couldn't say no. And I felt like pressured into making this decision. And every part of me was like, don't do that. Like, don't spend this money. You don't want to do this. This actually isn't going. This isn't the right decision for you. This isn't going to lead to a better outcome for you.
并不是因为我想给他留下深刻印象，而是我觉得自己无法拒绝。我感到被施压去做了这个决定。我内心的每一个声音都在说，别这么做。别花这笔钱。你不想这么做。这其实行不通。这并不是对你而言正确的决定。这不会为你带来更好的结果。
And yet I did it. And I really deeply regret it. I really deeply regret that I didn't listen to my intuition. And you know what? It wasn't a total loss. and in the grand scheme of things, like, yeah, it was a lot of money at the time. Like, I'm sure future me is not going, it is not, like, it wasn't like the amount that you would need to buy a house or even a car or anything like that big.
然而我还是做了。我对此感到非常深深的后悔。我真的深深后悔自己没有听从直觉。你知道吗？这并不是完全的血本无归，从宏观角度来看，嗯，当时确实是一大笔钱。我觉得未来的我肯定不会，它不像买房甚至买车那样需要一大笔钱。
But I just, I just wish that I had listened to myself a little bit better and that I had been more trusting in my own research and the information I had to make a better decision. And again, less peer pressured. I will also say this is a bonus regret that I talked about in the main episode that I did on this, the 20 Biggest Regrets episode. Not Investing Sooner was a big one for a lot of people in that episode, and it's a big one for me. Once you realize how many people are just like making money from their money,
但我只是，我只是希望自己当时能多听听内心的声音，并且能更信任自己的研究以及我所掌握的信息来做出更好的决定。再说一次，少受同辈压力影响。我还要补充一个额外的心愿/遗憾，这是我在主节目里谈过的，就是关于“20大悔恨”的那期节目。在节目里，没有早点投资对很多人来说是一大遗憾，对我而言也是如此。一旦你意识到有多少人在靠钱生钱，
like it's shocking and you never look back. And we're kind of at a point now where you don't necessarily need to be like a unicorn investor or a multi-millionaire to have access to these opportunities. I think like even $20 to $50, like you can put into shares or bonds or stocks and you can get returns. And I wish like, it's not free money. I will say it's not free money. I need to stop saying this. I said this to my friend the other day who was an accountant and she was like, you can't say that it's free money. but it is like your money working for you.
这简直让人震惊，而且你再也不会回头了。而且我们现在处于这样一个阶段，你不需要非得成为独角兽投资者或千万富翁才能接触到这些机会。我认为哪怕只要20到50美元，你就可以投入到股票、债券或基金中并获得回报。我希望，这不是免费的午钱。我要说明这不是免费的午钱。我得停止这么说。我前几天对一个当会计的朋友这么说过，她说你不能说那是免费的午钱，但这确实就像是你的钱在为你工作。
And so as a bonus, regret slash the thing I wish I'd done sooner, that is definitely one of them. I've kind of lost track of where I'm up to now. I think we are at number nine, our second last one. And that is not making the most of my time off when I was at university. Let me explain. I should have taken advantage of how, how little I had on when I was a university student.
所以作为额外的遗憾，或者说我希望自己早点做的事，这绝对是其中之一。我有点记不清现在讲到哪了。我想我们现在到了第九个，也就是倒数第二个。那就是在大学期间没有充分利用好假期。让我解释一下。我本该好好利用当大学生时空闲得多的优势。
I felt so much pressure to, like, have the internships to be applying for, like, as many jobs as possible and, like, boosting my resume and, like, making it look more important. Obviously, I also had to work because I needed to, like, pay my bills. But I also spent a great deal of time just, like, messing about and just, like, kind of hanging around my college and, like, not really. really doing anything. And I wish I hadn't done that. Like, you get to the stage and like adulthood and all the responsibilities just like kind of take over. And you realize how rare that time in your life was where you could just like have a little bit of freedom. Often like every seven weeks you would have like a
我当时感到巨大的压力，要去实习，要去申请尽可能多的工作，去充实我的简历，让它看起来更重要。当然，我也必须工作，因为我需要付账单。但我也花了很多时间只是瞎混，在大学里闲逛，实际上什么也没做。我真希望自己没有那样。等你到了成年这个阶段，所有的责任就会铺天盖地而来。你会意识到你人生中那段只需拥有那么一点点自由的时光是多么珍贵。通常每隔七个星期，你就会有一个
break. Every 12 weeks or so, you would have a break. And I wish I'd just done a few more day trips. I wish I'd done a bit more exploring. I wish I'd done a bit more of the stuff that excited me rather than what I thought I should have done. I remember one winter especially where I did this internship that everyone told me was important. I have never been asked about that internship. I even think that I got a job without that internship on my resume because it was an old resume that I handed in. Like, and it was so many hours of unpaid work that I thought was expected of me to get ahead in like the previous career that I was in and I just won't get that time back and I really think that my character and my sense of self and my like life enjoyment
休息。每12周左右，你就会有一个假期。我真希望自己当时能多进行几次一日游。我真希望自己能多做一些探索。我真希望自己能多做一些让我兴奋的事情，而不是去做那些我认为自己“应该”做的事情。我特别记得有一个冬天，我做了一份所有人都说很重要的实习。从来没有人问过关于那份实习的事。我甚至觉得我在简历上没有写那份实习的情况下也找到过工作，因为那是一份我交上去的旧简历。那有那么多小时的无薪工作，我曾以为这是我想要在之前的职业生涯中出人头地所必须付出的代价，而我再也找不回那些时间了。我真的认为，如果当时我只是去享受一些乐趣，我的性格、自我认同以及对生活的享受度
would have been improved so much better by just having some fun. I took my I took everything so seriously when I was finishing up uni and when I was in my final few years and months of university and I didn't appreciate how much freedom and how much fun like that time is and how you should really take advantage of it. Nowadays, it's like so much harder. I don't think I've had like a full week off without working in like two years. I wish that I realized what a gift that was back then and that there is so much time to get ahead and to do the shoulds and to do the things that you feel like obligated to do to get ahead later on. And yeah, someone else might be doing those things now, and you might feel like you're in this secret competition with all of these people. You're not.
将会得到多么显著的提升啊。我在大学快读完以及在大学的最后几年和几个月里，把一切都看得太严肃了。我没有意识到那段时光里有多少自由、多少快乐，以及你真的应该好好利用它。如今，情况要艰难得多。我觉得我已经有两年没休过一个不工作的完整假期了。我真希望自己当年能意识到那是一份多么宝贵的礼物，人生有的是时间去出人头地，去完成那些“应该”做的事，去履行那些你觉得为了以后出人头地而不得不承担的义务。是的，可能别人现在正在做那些事，你可能会觉得自己正和所有人进行着一场秘密竞赛。其实并没有。
People also want well-rounded individuals, and you can't be well-rounded if you just continuously do things that are expected of you or that you don't even care about just because of how they look. That's my ninth regret, and this is my final one. delaying medical appointments. Sounds like a weird one to make number 10 on this list. It is not. You guys know I had that really, well, maybe you don't know if you didn't listen to that episode, but at the start of the year I had this really intense health scare where I went to the optometrist and literally within days I was getting MRIs to see if I had a brain tumor and they were testing to see if I had MS or I had all of these different diseases.
人们也希望看到全面发展的人，而如果你只是不断地做那些对你有所期待、或者你根本不在乎但只是为了好看的事情，你就无法做到全面发展。那是我的第九个遗憾，而这是我的最后一个：拖延医疗预约。听起来把这个排在榜单第十位很奇怪。其实一点也不。你们知道我经历过那次非常，好吧，也许如果你没听过那期节目你可能不知道，但在今年年初，我经历了一次非常强烈的健康恐慌，我去了验光师那里，仅仅几天之内，我就去做了核磁共振（MRI），看看我是否有脑瘤，他们还测试我是否患有多发性硬化症（MS）或所有这些不同的疾病。
Essentially, my optic nerve in my eye was like really, really swollen. And yeah, I, oh my God, I should know what it's called. Optic neurosis, I think, is what the symptom is. And I just, I'd miss that. I'd been having all of these like weird things. And I hadn't obviously like paid attention to them. And then suddenly it was like, oh my God, my life is. flipped upside down in like a matter of seconds. Literally just last week I went and I did all of my
基本上，我眼睛里的视神经肿胀得非常非常厉害。是的，天哪，我应该知道它叫什么。视神经炎，我想这就是那个症状。而我竟然错过了。我之前一直有所有这些奇怪的症状，而我显然没有注意到它们。然后突然之间，就像是“天哪，我的生活在几秒钟内彻底颠倒了”。就在上周，我去做了我
appointments for the next year. I went and got my bloods done. I went and got like all of my like screenings done. I went and got a bunch of like ultrasounds and a bunch of other stuff just to like look at things that I have been annoying me and that obviously like causing pain or discomfort in my body that I would ordinarily just like ignore but I know I need to. I need to. to pay attention to now before they get worse. I always have to give this caveat. I live in Australia, right? God bless universal healthcare because all of those appointments cost me $50. And I really did take advantage of those perks. Like I really did get the whole, I got the whole like bodily review, the whole like I did everything. And so I know every time I give this piece of advice or I talk about this
接下来一年的所有预约。我去抽血化验了。我去做了所有的筛查。我去做了很多超声波检查以及其他各种检查，只是为了检查那些一直困扰我、明显在身体里引起疼痛或不适的事情。平时我通常会忽视它们，但我知道我现在必须注意，必须在它们恶化之前予以关注。我总是得加上这个前提。我住在澳大利亚，对吧？上帝保佑全民医保，因为所有这些预约只花了我50美元。我确实充分利用了这些福利。我真的把整个身体检查了一遍，我做了所有能做的事。所以每当我给出这个建议或谈论这个
regret. I always get people who are not in countries that are as blessed as Australia being like, that's not, that's not, like, obtainable for everybody. That's okay. You should still do it. If you have the means, if you have any form of means or any way of doing this, even if it's through, like, free programs, through your university, like, especially when you're young and it may be discounted, or you may still be underneath your parents' health insurance, go and do it. I also just got my skin checked for skin cancer, I spent a lot of time like baking my body in the sun when I was in my late teens and early 20s and I was like, I have to do this. I kept getting it put off. The peace of mind that I felt afterwards was so relieving. Please do it for me. Do it. Do it for us.
遗憾时，我总是遇到那些不在像澳大利亚这样幸福的国家的听众说：“这并不对每个人都适用，这不切实际。”没关系。你还是应该去做。如果你有经济条件，如果你有任何途径或方法来做到这一点，哪怕是通过免费项目、通过你的大学——尤其是当你年轻时可能还有折扣，或者你可能还在父母的医疗保险范围内——去预约检查吧。我还刚去查了皮肤癌，我青少年晚期和20岁出头时花了很多时间在阳光下暴晒，当时我想：我必须这么做。我一直把这事拖延着。事后我感受到的内心平静是如此令人宽慰。请为了我去做。去做吧。为了我们大家去做。
Go and do your medical appointments. It's worth it. And that also counts for your mental health as well. I haven't always been the best at that. I feel like I let things get to a crisis point sometimes before I take action and after everything I went through last year with my mental health, I'm definitely trying to be aware that that is a pattern for me and I'm trying to unlearn it. I think that's all of them.
去进行你的医疗预约吧。这是值得的。这同样适用于你的心理健康。在这方面我并不总是做得最好。我觉得有时我会任由事情发展到危机边缘才采取行动。经历了去年有关心理健康的种种之后，我绝对在努力意识到这是我身上的一个行为模式，并且我正在努力改掉它。我想这就是全部了。
I think we have done my 10 regrets. I do have one more on this list that I must have added number 11, letting people who I don't respect make me feel bad about myself. that's kind of a big one to end on but this is especially like to do with people online I talk so much about like how I'm so easy to rage bait I know this about myself I get so frustrated at people who like criticize other people online behind behind like a troll account or like a faceless profile or people who are like you you did that wrong and like they've never actually attempted to make anything in their life or like put themselves out there
我想我们已经列举了我的10个遗憾。我这单子上其实还有一个，我一定是在第11位加上了它：让那些我不尊重的人让我对自我感觉糟糕。这算是一个挺重大的压轴话题，但这种情况尤其跟网上的人有关。我经常谈到我有多容易被激怒（rage bait）。我很清楚自己这一点。我看到有人在网上匿名账号或无脸头像背后批评别人，或者那些说“你做错了”而他们自己实际上在生活中从未尝试过去创造任何东西、也从未真正展示过自己的人，我会感到无比沮丧。
and so this is one that I'm just like, I regret all the emotional time and energy. I invested into people that I would never meet who had opinions about me that were completely unfounded. That's like a little bonus one. If you are someone, and to be honest, I still don't know how to not do it. So it's an ongoing regret. Maybe that's why it didn't make the full list. But if you were someone who feels the same and who has easily been rage baited recently
所以我对此感到遗憾的是我投入的所有情绪时间和精力，这些都浪费在了那些我永远不会相见、对我的看法完全毫无根据的人身上。这就像是一个小小的额外话题。如果你也是这样的人——说实话，我至今仍不知道该怎么不去这样做，所以这是一个持续的遗憾。也许这就是为什么它没有进入完整榜单的原因。但如果你也是那种有同感、最近很容易被激怒
or is easily getting frustrated by people's opinions, You are not alone. But that's everything. That's everything on my list. And I feel like that list is going to change in the next couple, several years as like I get older and I feel like I'm going to learn more. So I think I might come back in the last season of the psychology of your 20s, the last season before I turn 30 and redo this list and see like where I've kind of, what ones I've overcome, which things I've learned from, which things I regret a little bit less. But for now, that's really what I'm taking away from my early and mid-20s. And I hope that if, you know, you're at a similar point in your life or if you're in
或者很容易对别人的看法感到沮丧的人，你并不孤单。但这就是全部了。这就是我清单上的全部内容。而且我觉得随着我年龄的增长、感觉自己学到了更多，这个清单在未来几年内将会发生变化。所以我想我可能会在《你二十岁的心理学》最后一季——在我30岁之前的最后一季——回来重新做这个清单，看看我在哪些方面有所超越，从哪些事情中吸取了教训，对哪些事情的遗憾变少了一些。但就目前而言，这正是我从20岁出头和二十多岁中期这段时光中领悟到的东西。我希望如果，你知道的，你正处于人生相似的阶段，或者如果你正处在
your early 20s, you can learn something from those regrets and maybe not make the same mistakes. Or maybe it's just the case that everyone has to go through some of this stuff and figure it out on their own. So whatever it is, I don't know. Hopefully it was helpful. And feel free to share your regrets below. I know we have that full episode, but I genuinely think that. that the easiest way to learn is obviously to make the mistake yourself.
20岁出头，你能从这些遗憾中吸取一些教训，也许就不会犯同样的错误了。或者也许每个人都必须经历这些事情，然后自己去摸索明白。所以无论如何，我不知道。希望这些对大家有所帮助。欢迎在下方分享你们的遗憾。我知道我们有完整的一期节目，但我真心认为，学习最简单的方法显然是自己犯错。
The second easiest way is to hear from others and reflect on their takeaways and their learnings from those moments. So if you feel the need to share, please do leave a comment below. What is your biggest regret in your 20s so far? Also make sure that you are following us on Instagram or you are following us wherever you are listening right now on Spotify, on Apple Podcasts. We also have a YouTube and we have a substantiubes. So if you want transcripts, I know a lot of people want that. If you want some of the studies, references to the studies that we cite in some of our episodes, that is now available.
第二简单的方法就是聆听他人的经历，反思他们从那些时刻中获得的收获和教训。所以如果你觉得有必要分享，请在下方留言。到目前为止，你二十几岁最大的遗憾是什么？同时也请确保在Instagram上关注我们，或者在此时此刻你正在收听的平台上关注我们，比如Spotify、Apple Podcasts。我们还有YouTube和一个Substack。所以如果你想要文字版（我知道很多人想要这个），如果你想要我们在部分节目中引用的研究报告和参考资料，现在都可以获取了。
There will be links in the description. There's links everywhere. Everyone's got a link to something, but it will be clear where it is. Follow that to find what you're looking for. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. Learn from your regrets.
说明栏里会有链接。到处都是链接。每个人都有某个东西的链接，但它会在哪里一目了然。顺着链接就能找到你想要的东西。但直到下一次，保重。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。从你的遗憾中吸取教训。
And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
她们都跟同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上，
or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
或者在您获取播客的任何地方。收听《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚克斯·英格利希。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师
and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
兼主持人基尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。